leanne what's going on hi uh
like i'm doing good doing good
[Laughter]
i don't get that i don't get that like
hey doing good
that makes me makes my heart feel good
no i have
i have some hard stuff to tell you but i
am blessed and so life
life is pretty good despite oh are you a
minimizer
no i like to think that i well
i okay you tell me
let's do it all right all right i feel
like you're going to drop some heavy
heavy heavy on here
well it is pretty heavy stuff um
five years ago five and a half years ago
my husband who was 39 years old i was
34.
i took his life oh yeah i'm sorry
yeah hard hard things i had seven
children ages 13
and under and a four month old on my hip
at the funeral
and uh all of with was he the father of
all seven
yes yes and we have been married 15
years whoa
um so the oldest at the time was 13
and he just really struggled with his
dad's death
it was very hard for him to overcome we
did counseling we did medication we did
treatment programs i did everything to
try to help him and
two years ago last month he took his
life and i found him
hanging in my shed and it was terrible
and is awful but
um i am now we're two years out and
obviously still very hard but the
problem i'm running into
hey hold on real quick real quick before
you get to the problem
stop there okay because you blew by that
pretty quick
that's a lot it is a lot
yes it's a lot and you've got
six other kids that you immediately
rallied around to take care of
that is a lot and here's the deal
leanne i've shown up i've been in that
exact scene
holding a mother in that exact moment
right that's a lot
it's pretty horrific yeah no
mother should ever
see that ever
i agree no
no wife should
ever experience that
and i know there's some sort of
challenge that has presented itself
today
but i don't want to get to that until
you hear me say i'm so sorry
thank you i appreciate that
man
okay so fast forward three years
so your son was 16. when he passed away
15 years old
two years so he's two years ago yes he's
16 he'd be
18 now um how was how was the graduation
was that a hard moment for you
it was when his friend started
graduating that it would be because a
lot of people don't get that
oh yeah so when his friends were
graduating yeah tonight that's a
nightmare
yeah and and i want you you're not
asking for this i don't think but as you
move through
um be super intentional to to
put stars on the calendar and
intentionally grieve those seasons okay
right and when they start graduating his
friends graduate college when you see
their facebook stuff when you see
when the first one of his old buddies
has a kid with all those moments
don't fight that just let that wash over
you
because it's gonna hurt right right
and that's that's part of the healing
and grieving process
so he dies by suicide three years ago
and then fast forward
you now you're a single mom with six
kids
yeah doing the single mom thing for five
years but now
oldest son's been gone two years so now
i have these six kids and
you know i work a mom and
i the struggle i'm running into is
these sweet kids it makes me emotional i
talk about it but
the hardest part is honestly just
watching my kids have to
age overnight and carry burdens that
would [ __ ]
grown grown adults and
just watching them try to have to
weather that and navigate that
and everyone's in counseling we have we
go
we go the whole nine yards um my
struggle though
and some do better than others of my
children but
um it's the older ones in particular
that kind of remember their brother the
most
really struggle with taking dad and
brother's death
personally that it means that i wasn't
lovable enough to keep them here and
then
maybe i'm not worthy and um you being
you being mom are you being like they're
they're feeling that individually their
voice
okay that their voice feels like because
i they voice they have voices to me
we're very open and speak openly about
all this stuff
and um that has been
a worry on a lot of their hearts is if
what does this mean
that dad really didn't love me if he's
willing to just
leave and does this mean brother never
even cared about me
if he would leave us in this situation
knowing how much it hurt
having losing a family member to this
because brother knew brother went
through it too
yeah so that's the struggle is i've told
them over and over and like i said
they're in so much counseling but
they're being told this has nothing to
do with you but
kids will i feel like just make it about
them
make it about if they were good kids or
if they're not good kids and
they i am having the hardest time
correcting that belief system that is
being created in some of them
that this was bigger than any of us it
was inside of them
and it had nothing to do with you and
still yet especially my 16 year old
daughter
just really feels like i could have
prevented this if i was a better girl
um
i hate that for you i know i keep saying
that i'm sorry that you're having to
navigate that
right um so you've if you've listened to
this show before i've talked about this
with marriages
this is one of those cases where it is
it's clear how it happens but kids feel
tension they absorb trauma and they make
it their fault
that's the only way they know how to
regulate themselves is with other people
and when other people
die by suicide they're left looking in
the mirror with nobody
and so they look at that gap between
them and somebody that they
loved who's no longer here and they say
that what did i do
right and what a good therapist will do
is help them
understand that that illness was in
somebody else's mind right
a good therapist will say it feels like
this
but here's the truth of those feelings
and
there is a part of being 16 17 18 we got
to weather that
and it's just an uncomfortable hard
season where you're going to really
struggle
and you're going to have to struggle to
not project this is you're reliving this
again
because now you got another 16 year old
absolutely and you're
it your brain is gearing up for
number two right it's
true it's been down this road before
and so the challenge you're going to
have is not what happened to your son
statistically speaking will not happen
again
right i sure hope not there you go
right it won't happen again but you and
i both know that it might
yeah right 99.99 chance that it won't
happen again
but you have lived the .001 and your
brain knows
that your heart knows that so it's on
full alert
and as i just said kids feel that
tension
and they're going to make it their fault
yes
and so we've already experienced that i
work on that in therapy for myself that
inside i'm like completely
overreacting and freaking out and
outside i have to be
i'm so sorry you feel that way let's
talk about that like you know
oh hold on hold on
i don't want to get in the middle of
your therapy right you're i'm assuming
you've got a great counselor
right but if you were my client
i'm not even licensed so am i going to
put that way here's what i'd recommend
to you just as a
as a neighbor okay okay
when you feel a mess inside
your daughter needs to feel that
congruence
she feels that you're a mess inside and
when your face is like hey baby how's it
going
she knows there's something not right
something's not
congruent there between your heart and
your in your body
and between your heart and what you're
saying to her
as one of my students who was on the
autism spectrum once said to me
i was laughing but i was also telling
him hey dude you can't have alcohol in
here and he said
your words are not matching your face i
need you to clarify for me
right it's a very similar situation so
the greatest gift you can give your
daughter
is to say i'm so scared because this is
when i lost your brother
and i love you more than life itself and
i'm scared
and then suddenly you become human and
then you become just like her
and suddenly she doesn't feel so crazy
anymore right
right does that make sense we've had yes
and we've had those conversations too
but i i am still
i am still working through the that my
son thing that
sometimes i feel like just freaking out
in a way that would scare her
and so very much i have to tone that
down that
i have had those conversations that what
you're saying is scaring me so like
let's talk about that like let's keep
talking about this but but you're right
like i do i almost probably go to the
other
the pendulum kind of swings the other
way that
i don't want to i don't want to scare
her i don't upset her and
challenging after you have lost a kid
because you were holding boundaries and
trying to parent them the way that you
know they need to be parented especially
when it's a son who doesn't have a dad
and then they kill themselves
it it it is hard to stay at that level
of parenting that you know is right for
your kids to hold boundaries
and expect things of them that kids need
to be able to do
um yeah
[Music]
your son's death was not your fault
my brain knows that my heart still
struggles
leanne i'm telling you right now your
son's death was not your fault and
you're still carrying it
yeah your son was a lovely hilarious
funny gross hairy-legged 16-year-old boy
whose head was not well
right and he died not your fault
right yes you've
got a scary endeavor it's so scary it's
the most scary it's your heart walking
outside of your body out in the
neighborhood right
right but you got to set that brick down
because when you're carrying that
gigantic cinder block of
somewhere deep down i i i'm responsible
for this
all that brick is taking up both of your
hands and you can't
fully grab and hug the life
into your other kids with all your might
right right
yeah and so your grief to quote the the
grief
the greatest grief guy on planet earth
david kessler your grief has to be
witnessed
someone's got to sit in it with you and
there is no better people on earth to
sit in it with you than those who
experienced it with you
right right have you all done those
exercise
exercises where you all especially you
and your
your 16 year old we all write them a
letter together
no we haven't i'd recommend that and
maybe ask your therapist to do that
um do y'all want to do that together all
three of you
but y'all write him a letter and or you
write one and she write one and you'll
read them
out loud in a counseling session
and in that letter you talk about how
much you miss him how mad at him you are
how much you love him and then the
beautiful the beautiful part of this
is you're both seeing you're both
letting your feelings that are on the
inside come be seen on the outside
and then you talk about who you're gonna
be
here's the kind of mom i'm gonna be
here's how we're gonna make meaning of
this mess
and what that begins to do for you for
you and your 16 year old is it begins to
plot a course for tomorrow
and when those that we love die by
suicide our tomorrow just goes away
right you just stumble through every
single day to get to the next day to get
to the next day
my guess is you've already mapped out
just like probably to the day
how many days you got left with all six
of these kids
right it is just how i can get through
today get to today get today get today
and it's hard and it's hard and it's
hard and once you
turn it i don't want that for them i
know i don't want that month to mom in
survival mode
leanne i don't want this for you you're
too extraordinary
you're too extraordinary and right now
you are living a life that you've got
duct taped and knitted
and nailed together because you're
trying to hold it together for them
and you've got to exhale and let that
thing go
and that means you're gonna have to let
your son go and you're still holding on
to him
because you still want to edit the story
because somehow you think you're the
author of what happened and you're not
okay and there's
nothing on this call i mean like what
has happened to you should not happen
i'm so so sorry
thank you and what i want for you is to
feel that i want your kids to feel that
their mom feels
i want their kids to know that my mom's
human and that she is a mess just like
we
are and that we miss miss our brother
miss miss dad that we super
are mad at them and we understand what
they did
and we don't understand it but we
understand that they weren't they
weren't well
all right then we're gonna start
shorting up charting of course for
tomorrow we're gonna make mean of this
stuff
and what a gift your gift is not gonna
be making sure they don't get any bumps
or bruises your
gift is gonna be letting them see your
bumps and bruises
yeah let them see your scars that's the
gift you give them at this point
and letting them know they're the most
precious special wonderful messes on
planet earth
right okay
i can do that i will do that but that
starts with you
letting this putting that brick down
yeah and it sounds a lot cooler yeah
super meg like
it's a cool thing to see on the radio
and then just like click over to the
next call
and you hang up and you're like what i
don't even do that start with a letter
okay right start with a letter
talk to him about that you're so sad
that you're missing graduation
and it's also awesome to see his buddies
graduating and you are pissed
that he's not graduating
maybe send his buddies a card
and congratulate them that's that's the
little bread crumbs towards making
meaning of this
doesn't he cheer on his classmates
right when you call his old girlfriend
and you
send her a note to say hey don't call
her because that could be kind of weird
but
um send a little card or something says
we miss you and
happy graduation whatever i don't know
what the what the story was there but
right um begin the slow that slow turn
into making meeting this thing
but i check on that start there with a
letter start there with your daughter
writing a letter
you doing it and i think reading out
loud to each other is going to humanize
you in front of your daughter
and remember this she's watching you
for her only picture of how
a strong wonderful mother a strong
wonderful woman deals with hurt
right and you want her to be able to
feel this to acknowledge it to own it to
to stumble and and cry and get dragged
down that river
of grief you wanted to experience all
those things
but you got to show her you got to model
it okay and that's how you end up
becoming well too
thank you so so much for your call ian
you're a brave wonderful woman
if you if you would be willing to it's
it'd be a brave thing but after you read
your letters to each other
um again preferably with your counselor
if you'll read your letters to each
other
i'd love for you to give me a call back
and let me know how that went i'd love
to know
um about how that moment was between you
and your daughter i think that's gonna
be a remarkable remarkable turn for your
family
thank you so much for the call